j'ai passé
j'ai cassé
cette action sociale
figaro live il est 11h 25 nous sommes le
jeudi 29 octobre 2020 on est en direct
pour parler de cette terrible attaque
qui s'est déroulée ce matin à nice dans
une église dans la basilique notre dame
de l'assomption précisément en plein
centre-ville attaque au couteau
perpétrée par un individu trois morts à
l'heure actuelle l'individu interpellé
grièvement blessé lors de l'intervention
et est transporté à l'hôpital on va
faire le point parce qu'évidemment cette
attaque survient en pleine préparation
du 2e confinement pour la france un
d'ailleurs jean castex qui était à
l'assemblée nationale eh bien à quitter
précipitamment l'hémicycle emmanuel
macron lui s'est rendu tout comme jean
castex à la cellule de crise au
ministère de l'intérieur place beauvau
un toujours à paris emmanuel macron qui
est en ce moment même en route vers nice
sur les lieux du drame
avenue jean médecin voilà c'est tout
près de cette artère que les faits se
sont déroulés on va d'ailleurs allé sur
place
dans un instant j'habite à nice nous dit
justement elle ragga taux qui est avec
nous sur twitter ont effectivement sur
tweets sur lefigaro.fr et sur youtube
pour vous résumer les faits qui ont
évolué de minute en minute c'est pour ça
qu'on n'a pas commencé le direct trop
tôt puisqu'il y avait beaucoup
d'incertitude l'ordre dans l'est dans
les instants qui ont suivi cette attaque
est ce que c'était dans l'église en
dehors alors deux personnes sont
décédées ont été découvertes mortes dans
l'église une autre est décédée des
suites de ses blessures en dehors de
l'édifice à c'est ce que confirment les
sources policières
à l'heure actuelle on va tout de suite
basculé du côté de nice on va retrouver
notre envoyé spécial vincent rose rond
bonjour vincent vous êtes du coup sur
cette avenue jean médecin tout près du
périmètre de sécurité puisque la zone a
été bouclée en vous êtes à à quelques
dizaines de mètres de cet édifice
religieux
oui effectivement perçu à une centaine
de mètres de la basilique qui se trouve
je vais vous montrer le périmètre
il ya beaucoup de gens qui se sont
rassemblés actuellement autour de 7,2
cette artère artères
très passante à l'habitude c'est
vraiment une artère principale de nice
et la basique de la sanction elle est
juste un peu plus loin des mois elle est
juste un petit peu plus loin là vous
voyez là je me trouve à la lisière du
périmètre elle a un petit peu plus loin
sur la gauche
comme vous pouvez le voir et y en a
aussi qui sont présents avec quoi on est
sur un périmètre de sécurité qui s'est
agrandie au fil des minutes depuis
l'attaqué qui a été perpétré semble-t-il
aux alentours de 9 heures oui c'est ça
de l'ataxie produite aux alentours de 9
heures un peu avant si si si si je crois
bien en fait le périmètre a été d'abord
restreint on pouvait aller presque pas
loin de la basilique qui rappelle un
tout petit peu plus loin sur la gauche
et le périmètre a été élargi il ya une
demi heure trois quarts d'heure
peut-être et aussi je voudrais vous dire
qu'il ya eu des détonations ont été
entendues à 10h30 pour faire exploser
des objets suspects oui d'ailleurs bien
les autorités ont communiqué sur twitter
ont appelé les riverains et les
habitants niçois ne pas s'inquiéter
puisque ces détonations ont fait suite à
l'intervention des équipes de déminage
c'est c'est la procédure on va prendre
vos questions à vos réactions êtes
nombreuses et nombreux à découvrir
eh bien les faits en direct on est sur
toi qui sur youtube sur lefigaro.fr je
vous rappelle que vous alentours de 9
heures donc une attaque au couteau a été
perpétré dans la basilique notre dame de
l'assomption à nice 3 morts l'un
l'auteur des faits interpellé grièvement
blessé et évacué à l'hôpital
un internaute qui habite à nice tout
comme vous à vincent nous dit c'est
l'avenue la plus fréquente et on va
préciser un lagon se trouve on est en
plein coeur de nice c'est ça on est sur
l'avenue jean médecin qui est la mieux
voilà on est là le périmètre de nice
étoile est l'un des centres commerciaux
le principal centre commercial du vieux
nice c'est là aussi où passe le tram le
tram est coupée maintenant vous voyez il
est juste derrière moi voilà c'est il ya
celle et c'est l'une des artères
effectivement principale de nice
effectivement je vais vous montrer aussi
notre direct texte sur lefigaro.fr on
est en événementiel pour vous faire
vivre
aussi cette situation vous allez pouvoir
voir et bien les équipes de déminage des
forces de l'ordre qui sont devant cette
basilique
les riverains qui sont sous le choc
justement vincent quelle est
l'atmosphère autour de vous qu'est ce
qu'on dit est ce qu'on est en train
d'apprendre ce qui s'est passé alors on
n'est plus vraiment en train de
l'apprendre puisque c'était passé il ya
quand même de deux heures un peu plus de
2h30
mais oui il ya un état de sidération
dents dans cette île qui vous rappellent
aussi été déjà touché le 14 juillet 2016
par un attentat qui a fait 86 morts
et effectivement il ya un état de
sidération autour de moi il y avait
beaucoup de tension ce matin quand je
suis arrivé sur place de la part des
gens de la part des de la part des
forces de l'ordre qui arrivait sur place
il y avait du mal à expliquer aux gens
qu'il y avait une urgence plus
importante que que s'occuper de leurs
petits problèmes on va dire mais voilà
bonjour à toutes et à tous sur
lefigaro.fr bonjour ac scène qui est
avec nous bonjour le rookie est là aussi
bonjour jr sur sur twitch bonjour
michael ça de news love from island très
mauvaise nouvelle
bah écoutez vous avez des ondes
positives depuis l'irlande merci pour
votre message michael combattons l'islam
radical nous dit ben alors on va
préciser que le parquet national anti
terroriste a ouvert une enquête pour
assassinat et tentatives d'assassinât en
relation avec une entreprise terroriste
un autre motif a été retenu association
de malfaiteurs terroristes criminels je
vous rappelle que les faits se sont
déroulés vers 9 heures à la basilique
notre dame de l'assomption c'est donc en
plein coeur de nice oui vous êtes
nombreux à nous le dire effectivement
nice et vincent oserons nous le
rappelait il ya quelques minutes
nice qui chaque année se rappelle
commémore ce terrible attentat de la
promenade des anglais ce camion fou qui
a fauché 86 vie il y avait eu plus de
450 blessés
c'est donc aussi un événement qui
rappelle un autre attentat qui était
survenue quelques jours après l'attaqué
à nice la tacc au camion bélier c'était
l'attentât à saint-etienne du rouvray
près de rouen en seine-maritime c'était
le 26 juillet 2016 attentats au cours
duquel est bien le père hamel avait été
égorgé un fidèle grièvement blessé et
les deux auteurs des faits avaient été
abattues d'après les éléments qu'on a en
tout cas vincent je sais pas si vous les
avez eu aussi en tout cas ça ne s'est
pas déroulé au cours d'une messe en
cette attaque alors sur ça je peux pas
vous répondre ce n'est pas trop
d'éléments les quand je suis arrivé
depuis six avaient déjà bloqué toute la
situation données d'informations
l'imaginer on va aussi vous montrer ce
qui est en train de se dérouler un du
côté de la place beauvau à paris c'est
le ministère de l'intérieur où une
cellule de crise est bien a été réuni
elle est en cours cette réunion cette
cellule de crise le premier ministre
jean castex lui il était à l'assemblée
ce matin il était à l'assemblée pour
quoi et bien parce que on est en train
d'examiner de débattre et de voter
eh bien les nouvelles mesures sanitaires
qui ont été annoncées par emmanuel
accro hier ce nouveau confinement qui
entre en vigueur la nuit prochaine
on est dans une parlementaire express
puisque ces mesures sont en train de
passer à l'assemblée nationale elles
vont prendre la direction du sénat dans
quelques minutes les députés se sont
levés ce matin puisqu'ils ont appris la
nouvelle de cette attaque au cours de
l'examen des nouvelles mesures
une minute de silence a été observée on
va vous montrer ça tout de suite grâce à
julien qu'une aile à la réalisation de
ce live parlementaire express
vous pouvez la retrouver sur lefigaro.fr
dans notre direct
les députés qui se sont donc levés et
qui ont observé une minute de silence la
séance a été suspendue
elle a repris 1 depuis puisqu'on est en
train d'examiner et de voter à quelques
heures seulement de leur entrée en
vigueur ces nouvelles mesures sanitaires
parmi lesquels bien sûr le nouveau
confinement qui entre en application à
partir de la nuit prochaine cette haine
est incroyable nous divisent um sur
youtube un auteur tout seul on nous dit
concrètement bachir alors pour l'instant
pour l'instant on parle d'un seul
individu qui a été interpellé et bien
conduit à l'hôpital puisqu'il aurait été
grièvement blessé lors de
l'interpellation je vous rappelle qu'à
l'heure actuelle et bien ce qu'on sait
c'est que cette attaque a fait trois
morts deux femmes un homme un homme et
une femme ont été découverts morts à
l'intérieur de l'édifice religieux
vous continuez à commenter on va se
retrouver dans un instant on va
retrouver aussi vincent rosereau on vous
laisse avec ces images et vous continuez
de réagir nous poser vos questions sur
youtube sur tric sur lefigaro.fr
au cou
m
[Musique]
non
à vue
m
[Musique]
ou pourquoi
on est toujours ensemble ils vous
continuez de réagir et nous poser vos
questions sur youtube sur lefigaro.fr
sur twitter suite à cette attaque au
couteau perpétrée ce matin aux alentours
de 9 heures en la basilique notre dame
de l'assomption en plein coeur de nice
trois morts deux femmes un homme c'est
ce qu'on sait à l'heure actuelle
l'auteur des faits qui a été muni d'un
couteau et bien a été interpellé
grièvement blessés conduits à l'hôpital
une enquête ouverte pour assassinat et
tentatives d'assassinât en relation avec
une entreprise terroriste enquête
ouverte
bien sûr par le parquet antiterroriste
on va lire vos commentaires en direct
c'est vraiment triste ce qu'il se passe
j'espère qu'ils n'ont qui n'ont pas
souffert en parlant des victimes c'est
ce que vous nous poster à ligne sur
youtube emilien nous dit de la haine de
la violence pure triste courage à vous
les français on va revenir en plateau
avec les réactions des différentes autos
liszt et d'autres autorités politiques
religieuses
avant ça on va retourner sur place
vincent rosereau envoyé spécial figaro
live en plein coeur de nice où on peut
lire sur les différents réseaux que bien
les niçois sont tout simplement
abasourdi par ce qui est en train de se
passer parce qu'ils apprennent et on
voit qu'il ya plus en plus de monde
autour de vous aux alentours de ce
périmètre de sécurité
effectivement alors il ya aussi beaucoup
de gens aussi qui ne peuvent pas rentrer
chez eux parce qu'il ya beaucoup de rues
qui sont ou ont été bloqués et du coup
en fait on a bloqué les routes et ces
gens là ne peut pas rentrer parce que
comme des immeubles dans lesquelles les
joies mais aussi parce qu'il ya des gens
qui sont au balcon de la basilique notre
dame un peu plus loin sur mes images en
haut à gauche
vous voyez un petit édifice alors je
veux pas trop zoomer mais envoie golfe
vous voyez est effectivement comme vous
le disais il ya été commises il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui travaillent
ici est vraiment pas mal de badauds qui
se sont qui se sont rassemblés la
sidération de là et attend et regarde ce
qu'on peut re préciser vincent sait
qu'on est vous vous trouvez en ce moment
sur l'avenue jean médecin qui est
vraiment une des avenues les plus
commerçantes et donc les plus fréquentés
de nice
oui bien sûr voilà c'est l'avenue qui
est très proche qui est très commerçante
et l'avenue principale de nice via la
gare aussi qui est juste au dessus des
gens qui voulaient aller à la gare font
mal à y aller aussi puisque le secteur
était bloqué
je me trouvais là le pire ne s'arrête
devant ses toiles qui est l'un des
centres principal de et il ya aussi aux
fans que pour voir si c'est vraiment
voilà l'artère principale de nice qui
est bloqué en ce moment je ne sais pas
sur combien de mètres parce
qu'effectivement ça a l'air de reprendre
un peu plus loin au pour vous voyez tout
au fond là bas mais je pense pas que
vous verriez la loire 500 mètres plus
loin on apprend sur un bloc cette avenue
sur 500 m et 20 cents autres questions
on se situe ou par rapport à la
promenade des anglais là où ou ce camion
bélier et son et son chauffeur
terroriste avait fauché 86 vie en 2016
eh bien on se situe pas très loin d'un
institut à peu près km vous voyez
derrière moi y'a le permis sécurité avec
avec l'église notre dame
en fait si on continue un peu plus loin
si on réussit on redescend la route de
l'autre côté on arrive sur la pomme là
vous voyez derrière moi il ya le tram
est derrière vous avez la mer en fait ce
qui est un peu plus loin vers la bas
merci vincent heureusement vous êtes
notre fil rouge envoyé spécial au coeur
de nice un tout près du lieu du drame
on va évidemment prendre vos réactions
vos questions je vois que vous êtes
nombreux à nous demander alors par
exemple si le tueur est en vie nous dit
nous demande patrick à l'heure actuelle
ce qu'on sait c'est qu'il a été
interpellé grièvement blessé lors de
l'intervention rapide des forces de
l'ordre intervention saluée par par
christian estrosi d'ailleurs on va faire
un focus justement sur ces réactions des
politiques et du monde religieux bonjour
vincent roux rédacteur en chef figaro
live vous vous êtes pencher notamment
sur les questions religieuses s'étaient
notamment lorsque vous travaillez chez
nos confrères de lci
quelles sont les réactions à l'heure
actuelle on a notamment la conférence
des évêques de france qui s'est exprimé
oui bah en tout cas son président à
l'archevêque de reims à monseigneur 2
eric de moulins beaufort qui a twitté en
fait tout a l'air ma prière pour les
victimes et leurs proches
dimanche pour la toussaint nous
entendrons le seigneur heureux des
artisans de paix ils seront appelés fils
de dieu heureux si on vous persécutent à
cause de bois car votre récompense sera
grande dans les cieux c'est une citation
d'un d'un évangile l'évangile quand
l'appel sur les béatitudes une dizaine
de béatitude qui font écho aux dix
commandements qui sont prononcés par
jésus sur la montagne et qui sont
également une méditation sur un cercle
c'est le paradoxe est réduit à un moment
heureux ceux qui pleurent parce qu ils
seront consolés donc c'est ça a été donc
une première réaction assez spirituel on
va dire deuxième tweet de monseigneur de
moulins beaufort qui assurent toutes les
les
les dieux c'est ce qu'il appelle les
diocésains donc les catholiques de nice
de sa prière toute spéciale et en
particulier l'évêque monseigneur marceau
qui sache se soutenir dans cette épreuve
et soutenir ceux qui sont éprouvés dans
leur chair on a également la réaction du
conseil français du culte musulman qui
condamne je cite l'attentât terroriste
c'est la formule qui est employé donc
sur le site du compte officiel du compte
twitter officiel du champ du cfcm et qui
annonce
là en signe de deuil l'annulation des
festivités du bolide
c'est à dire la commémoration de la
naissance selon la foi musulmane du
prophète du prophète mahomet et qui doit
à lui lieu le 29 le 29 octobre on peut
préciser que du côté des musulmans et du
côté des chrétiens on est sur une
semaine chargée en alors c'était
d'ailleurs l'un des enjeux avant cet
attentat par rapport au confinement
c'est à dire que selon les informations
de leur retrouver du figaro les
responsables religieux français
musulmans également catholique avait
obtenu un sursis de la part du
gouvernement pour pouvoir procéder ou
aux célébrations et aux célébrations de
ces fêtes pour les chrétiens c'est la
fête de la toussaint qui a lieu ce
week-end qui aura lieu dimanche le et
puis le lendemain la le la commémoration
du jour des morts
donc la toussaint est quand même on
signale il y avait déjà depuis plusieurs
jours
l'information selon laquelle il y avait
une note de la direction de la police
nationale qui a annoncé le renforcement
de la vigilance pour la toussaint autour
des édifices religieux
li a toujours un déploiement de sécurité
autour des édifices religieux autour des
églises autour des cathédrales
dès qu'il y à un grand rassemblement je
n'ai vu un notamment il ya une quinzaine
de jours dans la région parisienne on a
maintenant des militaires de l'opération
sentinelles armées qui sont sur les
parvis à assurer la protection et
surtout à regarder autour d'eux s'il ya
eu une éventuelle attaque
la hantise étant à chaque fois qu'il y
ait une attaque une attaque de masse
comme on a pu le voir une attaque en
tous les cas à l'explosif contre
justement des rassemblements quand les
gens sortent notamment de des édifices
religieux des églises comme on a pu le
voir dans un certain nombre de pays
étrangers notamment en egypte notamment
en irak notamment en syrie notamment
également en afrique en 2013 par exemple
au mali à bamako les catholiques disait
notre hantise c'est que il se passe chez
nous ce qui se passe au nigeria qu'est
ce qui se passait au nigeria à côté
c'était des attaques à la voiture piégée
ou bien des attaques à la veste
explosive
les autres cas des attentats kamikazes à
l'intérieur des églises là c'est pas du
tout apparemment tous les cas là le
modus operandi qui qui a eu ça reste en
tous les cas une hantise et en
particulier une hantise des autorités
sans parler bien sûr de déjà de deux
l'alertent qui avait été lancé dans nos
colonnes dans les colonnes du figaro par
l'avocat thibault de montbrial et par le
spécialiste de l'anti terrorisme
jean-charles brisard sur l'augmentation
de la menace terroriste augmentation de
cette menace qu'on avait pu vérifier
hélas avec l'attentât contre et le
meurtre
de samuel pâtit parler aussi des
réactions politiques notamment celle du
maire de nice christian estrosi avant ça
je prends le commentaire de nogueira sur
youtube
quelle honte de faire une chose pareille
dans un lieu de culte
cette attaque est en train de nous
rappeler évidemment saint-etienne du
rouvray le 26 juillet 2016 le père hamel
la banlieue de rouen
mais ce n'était pas une mais ce matin au
moment d'une messe n'était pas en cours
au moment du du drame semble-t-il en
tous les cas d'après les informations
qu'on a et d'après les informations que
nous donne des dénis soir qui sont sur
place
outre vincent oseront qui nous indique
que selon toute vraisemblance la messe
quotidienne à l'église notre dame de
l'assomption à la basilique notre dame
de l'assomption à nice a lieu à 11
heures
donc c'était s'est par contre c'est une
c'est une basilique où il y as
énormément de ce qu'on appelle de la
piété populaire
beaucoup de gens qui viennent se
recueillir poser des cierges faire une
prière avant 2 2 dans l'eure dans leurs
activités on est on le voit bien un
juste à côté donc de cette grande artère
qui relie la gare de nice a quasiment
quasi membres le front de mer pas
complètement mais où il ya toute cette
artère commerçante est on est on voit
bien qu'il ya on est à côté du tram est
donc celle à la basilique d'à côté d'une
station de tram la question d'ailleurs
qui se posera c'est de savoir si
justement là l'assaillant a profité de
ces de cette infrastructure pour pour se
rendre et pour aller dans l'église et
pour pour commettre son acte
justement le profil de cet individu qui
a été interpellé mais pour l'instant il
ya extrêmement peu d'informations qui
filtrent il ya peu de détails
donc on n'a pour l'instant que des
indications qui filtrent sur les réseaux
sociaux on ne redonne pas écho peut-être
qu'elle se vérifieront on sait pour
l'instant qu'il est
grièvement blessé on ne sait pas comment
s'est passée en tous les cas à l'heure
où je vous parle je n'ai pas vu comment
s'était passé exactement les conditions
d'interpellation on va voir si ce qu'on
peut lire en tous les cas sur les
réseaux se vérifie on va imiter en tous
cas de dire des bêtises et s'adonner à
ce jeu des suppositions
pour l'instant ce que l'on sait ce que
l'on sait c'est qu'il n'est pas ce qu'il
n'est pas mort al'inverse deux ans tout
n'a pas été tué sur le coup
al'inverse de l'assassin de l'assaillant
de saint-etienne du rouvray
deux assaillants les deux assaillants
auquel vous avez fait
fait allusion donc le 26 juillet 2016
on va retourner bien sûr cette avenue
jean médecin à nice retrouver vincent
rosereau vincent une question puisque
emmanuel macron est attendue est ce que
ça s'agite autour de vous en vue de
cette arrivée du chef de l'état a encore
pas encore encore parce que alors il ya
toujours un va-et-vient des villes de
secours on avait pas mal de ses débuts
sur médine âge mais on voit des
véhicules de pompiers d une police qui
passe nous aller retour et qui rentre
dans ce périmètre par les voies du tram
que vous pouvez voir ici le tram qui est
coupée bien évidemment les minima qu'on
va annoncer qu'ils se rendaient sur
place savoir qu entre nice et paris il
ya à peu près une heure et quart d'avion
donc il sera pas là tout de suite on ne
sait pas encore à quelle heure on
l'attend on avait dit la fin de matinée
mais on va attendre de voir
effectivement passé merci beaucoup
vincent on vient on revient vers vous
dans quelques minutes si vous nous
rejoignez sur youtube sur lefigaro.fr
sur twitter
je vous rappelle qu'une attaque au
couteau étaient perpétrés aux alentours
de 9h ce matin dans la basilique notre
dame de l'assomption à nice un tout près
de cette avenue jean médecin c'est à
dire en plein coeur de la ville avenue
jean médecin que vous voyez sur ces
images en direct de nos confrères de la
fp trois personnes sont mortes deux
femmes un homme deux de ses victimes ont
été trouvés découverte à l'intérieur de
l'édifice
une troisième personne qui était sorti
avec une plaie à la gorge indiquent des
témoins et bien est décédé de ses de ses
blessures est semble-t-il vincent roux
on a au moins une des victimes qui a
donc été égorgées qu'on a découvert dans
l'édifice qui ferait donc deux avec
cette victime qui est décédée des suites
de ses blessures
c'est en tout cas ce qu'a nié et rosie
dans un de ses tweets le christian
estrosi donc le maire de nice bouleversé
par les trois victimes dit-il dont deux
décédés à l'intérieur de la basilique
notre dame et notamment le gardien
christian estrosi qui précise que ce
gardien était très apprécié par les par
les paroissiens question d'un gardien
juste précision à un gardien dans une
église c'est s'il fait son office c'est
à dire que il s'assure que la l'édifice
soit ouvert soit fermé il fait
l'annoncent quand il quand il y a quand
il vit tant qu il va falloir fermer ils
salissent marc dont il s'assure que les
choses sans toit sont sont aux ordres
que s'il ya quelqu'un de suspect il le
signale bon généralement c'est plutôt
des hôpitaux des sdf ou comme ça qui à
un moment viennent demander de l'aide ou
comme ça donc ils gèrent un petit peu ce
genre de choses et il va le signaler à
aux prêtres ou bien aux gens qui est
bénévole qui travaille dans dans la
paroisse ou dans l'église il ya de moins
en moins deux gardiens faut quand même
le dire aujourd'hui
dans les églises en france parce que il
faut les il faut les payer et
l'église de france moins en moins
d'argent et et encore plus après le
après le confinement où les dons se sont
effondrés donc il y à des gardiens dans
les grands édifices et sinon très
souvent les églises sont fermés du fait
même de de l'absence de gardien l'autre
d'ailleurs l'autre fonction des gardiens
c'est de veiller également qu'il n'y ait
pas de profanations d'églises de
profanation par n'importe quel individu
également les attaques satanisme
notamment contre le tabernacle qui est
le lieu où selon la foi catholique
il y à la présence réelle du christ donc
ça tout ça c'est la fonction de ses
gardiens et c'est intéressant
de voir que ça il fait partie des
victimes c'est à dire que on peut
supposer c'est aller au jeu des
suppositions mais on peut supposer que
il a fait soit son travail en essayant
de de se rendre sur la scène
ou bien il a été la première victime
c'est en tout cas ce sera l'une des
questions qu'ils soient qui seront
intéressantes à apposer alors vous les
avez qui sont déjà à l'entrée des
églises où il parfois ils sont tournant
dans sa vie parisienne notamment où vous
avez dire je retiens on trouve les
gardiens dans les grands édifices
aujourd'hui cette basilique
qu'est ce qu'on sait sur cette basilique
alors ce qu'on sait sur cette basilique
c'est une basilique qui datent du 19e
siècle elle a été bâtie au moment du
rattachement de nice à la france nice
est l'un dès 1866 et la savoie et nice
et le comté de la savoie qui sont donc
les derniers rattachement
en tout cas la france au territoire
métropolitain et ça s'appelle notre-dame
précisément en référence à notre dame de
paris dont ça se voulait la la copie
typique dix neuvième siècle de ces
églises qui ont retrouvé soit le goût du
moyen-âge soi le goût de une certaine
renaissance donc voilà style néo néo
médiévale inspiré on va vous la montrer
tient sur sur google effectivement on
inspire à notre dame est inspiré de
notre dame file donc c'est une c'est ce
qu'on appelle une basilique donc une
basilique s'est servi dans le lieu
intermédiaire si vous voulez entre la
l'église de la rue de la halle allez on
va faire l'oratoire la chapelle l'église
la basilique la cathédrale et c'est
toujours des endroits qui sont des
lieu important de prière
et par exemple saint-pierre
contrairement à ce qu'on croit saint
pierre de rome n'est pas la cathédrale
de rome même si le pape qui habite juste
à côté et l'évêque de rome
mais saint pierre est une basilique
c'est là où on vient prier et se
recueillir notamment sur les reliques
d'un saint et là en l'occurrence en
l'occurrence à saint pierre c'est celle
de saint pierre mais également bon là
c'est beaucoup de basilic s'appelle
notre dame en hommage à notre dame est
c'est une façon d'exalter également à la
fois le catholicisme est également une
certaine identité l'identité chrétienne
de la france parce qu'on lui peut-être
mais dans la région catholique la la
reine de france sait c'est la vierge
marie
on parlait de
la région évidemment nice tout près de
l'italie justement le premier ministre
italien giuseppe comté vient de réagir
ils dénoncent
une ville attaque après donc cette
agression au couteau qui a fait trois
morts dans
et dehors puisque une victime a tenté de
s'échapper de l'édifice cette basilique
notre dame de l'assomption à nice la
ville attaque qui s'est produite à nice
n'ébranle pas le front commun en défense
des valeurs de liberté et de paix nos
certitudes sont plus fortes que le
fanatisme la haine et la terreur c'est
ce qu'il a écrit sur son compte twitter
ya d'autres réactions politiques
les réactions politiques notamment c'est
à la france a soumis ce qu'on a réagi
très tôt ce matin alexis corbière jean
luc mélenchon jean luc mélenchon qui
parle de solidarité ému avec les
catholiques de france philippe de
villiers également sur twitter qui dit
pour la première fois dans l'histoire de
france nous avons une toussaint
ensanglanté est confiné il fait la
jonction entre les deux événements
l'attentât de nice et les annonces du
président de la république hier sur le
gros confinement la cause est simple
selon l'ancien patron du mouvement pour
la france le pays n'est plus gouverné
tout est hors de contrôle
l'insurrection civique des proches
croient savoir en tout cas philippe de
villiers on a également d'autres
d'autres
réactions politiques ce qui était assez
frappant d'ailleurs ce matin c'était de
voir que pendant même alors même que le
premier ministre achevé son discours sur
les modalités d'application du
confinement soumises donc présenté aux
députés le président de l'assemblée
nationale richard ferrand a annoncé
la nouvelle de l'attentât et qu'il ya eu
tout de suite une minute de silence une
polémique d'ailleurs ensuite en tribune
avec notamment la son sable du groupe
socialiste valérie rabault qui a
reproché au gouvernement de maintenir le
débat alors qu'il y avait la nouvelle de
cet attentat à nice même temps le cadre
est extrêmement serré puisque ce nouveau
confinement est censée débuter la nuit
prochaine
d'ici demain matin même si au début va y
avoir une tolérance donc et on sait
toujours pas si la conférence de presse
d'ailleurs de de jean castex qui est
prévue à 18h30 que vous pouvez retrouver
sur figaro live est pour l'instant
maintenue on va retourner un sur cette
avenue jean-médecin retrouver vincent
oseront vincent on voit les policiers
les pompiers aussi qui continue à faire
des allers et venues est ce que le le
périmètre de sécurité toujours eux aussi
attendus tout à l'heure
oui je viens alors pierre excusez moi
oui pierre effectivement je suis
syndicaliste vous présenter monsieur
stimuler la vie d'olivier david olivier
reverdy séparation d'avionique à
m'expliquer ce qui s'est passé ce matin
j'étais vers 9 heures du matin et un
individu est entré dans l'église notre
dame situé en arrière la plus patiente
de l'union
il n'y avait pas d'office religieux à
cette heure ci me le dire en premier
lieu c'est un menu donc armé d'un
couteau s'en est pris à une dame âgée de
70 ans aurait égorgé puis continuer son
périple meurtrier et aurait aussi tué un
homme
cette fois ci est toujours à l'intérieur
de l'église avant que des témoins avant
d'être témoin l alerte était rapidement
sur place des policiers municipaux
arrivent à le neutraliser
avant quoi malheureusement une troisième
victime n'était à déplorer à me bouger à
lexar de l'église est d'accord l'auteur
des faits a été neutralisée à
l'externalisation été neutralisée
également à l'extérieur de l'église est
très rapidement après les faits une
poignée est là
les gens sont rapides donc de la police
municipale mais également rapidement
après des forces d'intervention du raid
de la berri et de l'ensemble des
équipages vers la police niçoise
vous avez parlé de deux courses et pour
l'instant il ya des caméras turrian ce
qui brille de 81 ans quittera tu de ton
qui nous permettra d'en savoir plus
bientôt
oui alors la ville de nice est une des
villes les plus dotés en france de
vidéosurveillance et il y a
effectivement une caméra de
vidéosurveillance visible devant le fil
devant match et de l'église
donc j'imagine qu'aujourd'hui les
enquêteurs sont contraints de de
visualiser et d'essayer de remonter bien
en amont pour voir le périple meurtrier
de l'individu était il seul était il
accompagné
comment se sont déroulés les faits
commencent les différentes la scène de
crime
donc ça c'était ça fait partie du
travail dgt en quête de nos collègues de
la police judiciaire du service de
l'antiterrorisme français et de la dge
si on a pas encore d'informations sur ce
il a eu des quantités ou non pour le
moment on n'a aucune information quant à
présent sur une éventuelle complicité ou
pas et c'est un élément isolé at il a
agi sur instructions à style agi avec
des complices il est beaucoup trop tôt
paul ii a bien merci beaucoup monsieur
oui on a très bien entendu merci
beaucoup
vincent rozon pour cette interview en
direct de david olivier reverdy du saint
lys du syndicat alliance police
nationale qui nous a donc donné des
précisions qui a confirmé que cette
attaque n'a pas eu lieu
pendant l'office pendant une messe alors
qu'on voit sur vos images que et bien
les forces de l'ordre s'approche et bien
d d voilà pour laisser passer un fourgon
de police
pas d' attaque pendant l'office une dame
de 70 ans qui aurait été égorgé un le
conditionnelle quand même employé par
par david olivier reverdy égorgée dans
l'édifice un homme a également été tué
donc si on recompose le puzzle un
vincent roux
il s'agit du gardien auquel faisait
référence le maire de nice christian
estrosi sur twitter et puis cette
deuxième femme plus jeune plus jeune
engagée de moins de 70 ans qui est donc
décédé des suites de ses blessures
aux alentours de l'édifice aux alentours
de l'édifice je sais pas si si vincent
se retrouve encore à proximité de l'ide
reverdy mais ce serait olivier reverdy
ce serait intéressant qu'on est là qu'on
est en tout cas une autre cet autre
précision est ce que comme on peut le
lien on peut l'entendre le l'assaillant
aurait crié allah akbar lors de la de
son de son interpellation
et est ce qu'on en sait un petit peu
plus tout simplement sur sur cette
identité sur l'identité de l'assaillant
et sur la nature de cette attaque d'une
attaque terroriste
ça semble faire aucun doute vu que le
parquet national anti terroriste clède
et gsea sont sur le coup en revanche su
ce qu'il s'agit d'une attaque et nathan
d'une attaque islamiste
on le présume mais en tous les cas on
aimerait bien en avoir la confirmation
l'élevage oui allez y et vincent vous on
est toujours sur place
il est en interview avec une autre une
autre chaîne j'essaierai de lui demander
mais tout à l'heure il parlait à des
collègues avant il m'a pas donné cet
élément peut lire posé la question je
pense qu il ne l'avait pas encore bien
justement c'est ça qui on aimerait bien
avoir justement cette cette confirmation
est pour l'instant on ne se laisse pas
aller une fois encore aux
aux spéculations à merci en tous les cas
de c2c de ces précisions
donc on disait bien que c'était pas
pendant un office de nice on sait qu
emmanuel macron sera sur place en début
d'après midi
on va vous faire vivre et évidemment
quand il sera arrivé bien son son sa
venue c'est une éventuelle déclaration
savoir s'il ya des infos nouvelles infos
qui vont s'ajouter vous pouvez toujours
en attendant suivre notre direct texte
notre live texte sur lefigaro.fr je vous
rappelle qu aux alentours de 9 heures un
individu est donc entré dans cette
basilique notre-dame de nice en plein
coeur de la ville
il a tué trois personnes 1 2 ont été
découvertes dans l'édifice une femme un
homme et puis une autre femme est
décédée en sortant en voulant se
réfugier dans un commerce voisin
l'assaillant qui d'après des sources
policières les proches de l'anc est dit
être âgé de 25 ans est ce qu'il aurait
déclaré lors de son interpellation il a
été grièvement blessé par balle lors de
son interpellation conduit à l'hôpital
il aurait donc déclaré à trajet de 25
ans tout cela va bien sûr être vérifiée
merci en tout cas nous avoir suivi sur
lefigaro.fr surtout sur youtube je vous
le disais les dernières déclarations
les dernières infos sont à vivre sur
lefigaro.fr notre live texte et puis on
se retrouve en direct évidemment dès que
la situation le justifie